From WBEZ Chicago, it's This American Life.
来自芝加哥WBEZ广播电台，这里是《美国生活》。
I'm going to take your mind to a state of enhanced mental imagery. You will clearly remember everything I tell you, and you will do everything that I tell you to do. I want you to imagine being on a beautiful deserted beach.
我将带你的思绪进入一种增强心理意象的状态。你会清楚地记住我告诉你的每一件事，并且你会去做我让你做的每一件事。我要你想象自己正身处一个美丽而荒凉的海滩上。
I want you to picture yourself lying on a beach chair, staring out at the ocean. You're watching the waves gently rolling into the shore. Wave after wave, gently rolling into the shore. And with each wave, you're becoming more and more relaxed, calm, and at peace. You can feel yourself relaxing now. You're watching wave after wave gently rolling into the shore. And you are now totally relaxed, calm, and at peace.
我要你想象自己躺在沙滩椅上，凝视着大海。你看着海浪轻轻地拍打着海岸。一波又一波，轻轻地涌向岸边。随着每一波海浪，你变得越来越放松、平静，心境平和。你现在能感觉到自己正在放松。你看着海浪一波又一波地轻轻涌向岸边。你现在已经完全放松、平静，心境平和了。
I'm now going to count from one to five. And when I get to the count of five, you will remember to do what you have been trained to do, and you will be awake, alert, and absolutely confident that you will pass your polygraph test. One. Two. Three. Four. Five.
我现在要从一数到五。当我数到五时，你会记得去做你被训练要做的事，你会变得清醒、警觉，并绝对自信你能通过测谎仪测试。一。二。三。四。五。
This is Douglas Williams, and this is part of a story created by the podcast Love + Radio, a story put together by Jacob McClelland, Ana Adlerstein, Steven Jackson, and Nick van der Kolk. If you don't know about Love + Radio, they're masters at doing these stories that unfold and slowly reveal what they're about over time with no narration. And this story does that beautifully.
这是道格拉斯·威廉姆斯（Douglas Williams），这是由播客节目《Love + Radio》创作的故事的一部分，由雅各布·麦克莱兰（Jacob McClelland）、安娜·阿德勒斯坦（Ana Adlerstein）、史蒂文·杰克逊（Steven Jackson）和尼克·范德科尔克（Nick van der Kolk）共同完成。如果你不了解《Love + Radio》，他们擅长讲述这些故事：通过没有旁白的方式，随时间推移缓慢展开并揭示主题。这个故事完美地做到了这一点。
And we're just going to jump in and start our show with this. Quick warning that we've unbeeped some curse words in this internet version of the program. If you prefer a beeped version-- maybe you're listening with kids-- it's at our website.
我们直接进入主题，以这个故事开始我们的节目。友情提醒，这个互联网版本的节目中，我们没有对脏话进行消音处理。如果你更喜欢消音版——也许你是和孩子们一起听——可以去我们的网站收听。
The story begins when the guy at the center of it, Douglas Williams, is in his 20s, and joins the police force in Oklahoma City.
故事开始时，核心人物道格拉斯·威廉姆斯正值20多岁，加入了俄克拉荷马城的警察部队。
I actually couldn't believe they actually paid me to do it. I loved it so much, especially the first year. They sent me to New York City for polygraph school at the National Training Center of Lie Detection in New York City. And in 1972, I became a certified polygraph expert.
我简直不敢相信他们竟然付钱让我做这份工作。我太热爱它了，尤其是第一年。他们把我送到纽约市的国家测谎培训中心接受测谎培训。1972年，我成为了一名认证的测谎专家。
So after that, I just was running polygraph examinations for criminal suspects, police applicants, and all internal affairs investigations. When you're working in internal affairs, you've narrowed your circle of friends down to a big fat zero because the police officers are all frightened of you, too, because they've seen you come into their little break room prior to their shift change. And I walk out then walked in there quite a few times, and they'd be in there shooting pool and having fun, talking to one another, and I'd walk in and it'd get dead silent. Everybody would look at me.
在那之后，我一直在为刑事嫌疑人、警员申请者和所有内部事务调查进行测谎。当你从事内部事务工作时，你的朋友圈子会缩减到零，因为警察们也都很怕你，因为他们曾看到你在轮班前走进他们的小休息室。我进去了好几次，他们原本在打台球、玩乐、互相交谈，我一进去，里面就变得死一般的寂静。每个人都盯着我看。
I'd run two or three tests a day. Some days I didn't have any at all to run. But that's all I did was run polygraph tests.
我每天要做两三次测试。有些日子根本不用做。但我做的一切就是进行测谎测试。
I became very cognizant of the fact that fear has a very distinct smell. I've heard it described as a mixture of shit and spinach, and that's a pretty close description. It truly does have a very distinct odor. The smell lingered in my office. I smelled it every day. It was there when I closed up the office at night. It was there when I opened up the office in the morning, almost like a fog or something.
我非常清楚地认识到，恐惧有一种非常独特的气味。我听说有人把它描述为屎和菠菜的混合味，这个描述相当贴切。它确实有一种非常独特的气味。这种气味在我办公室里挥之不去。我每天都能闻到。晚上关上办公室门时它在那儿。早上打开办公室门时它也在那儿，就像雾气或其他什么东西一样。
I got really good at doing what I did. I mean, I could literally scare the hell out of people with that thing. For instance, one of the props they told you to use was a little plastic heart like the doctors have in their office that comes apart and shows the left ventricle and the right ventricle and the cutaways and what-have-you. And it gets you that, and leave that sitting on your desk.
我做这份工作变得非常出色。我是说，我真的能用那玩意儿把人吓个半死。例如，他们让你使用的道具之一是一个小的塑料心脏，就像医生办公室里那种可以拆开，展示左心室、右心室、切面图之类的东西。你得到它，然后让它摆在你的桌子上。
When you get into your interrogation, you tell everybody that comes in, you tell them, OK, now, when you lie, you'll not be able to control yourself. And you reach over there and you get that little heart, and you take it apart and you put one part in your left hand and one part in your right hand. And you start getting them, and you say, OK, now, you know when you lie-- when you lie, your heart's going to start beating faster and faster and faster and faster and faster. And you slam those pieces of heart back and forth, back and forth, back and forth, faster and faster and faster, and you will not be able to control it. You will not be able to lie to me without your heart going bam! Bam! Bam! Bam! Bam! Bam! Bam!
当你进行审讯时，你告诉每一个进来的人，你告诉他们：好的，现在，当你撒谎时，你将无法控制自己。然后你伸手拿过那个小心脏，把它拆开，一只手拿一部分。你开始抓住他们，你说：好的，现在，你知道当你撒谎时——当你撒谎时，你的心脏会跳得越来越快、越来越快。然后你把心脏的两部分猛地撞在一起，啪！啪！啪！跳动得越来越快，你将无法控制它。你不可能在我面前撒谎而不让你的心脏砰砰直跳！
It was just so dramatic, but I tried it a few times. It actually worked pretty good. It got people's attention. I don't know if it was because of the demonstration or because they just thought, man, I'm talking to a crazy man here.
这太戏剧化了，但我试了几次。它确实非常有效。它吸引了人们的注意力。我不知道是因为演示还是因为他们只是想：天哪，我正在和一个疯子说话。
It's a damn good interrogation technique. Since we can't beat the hell out of people physically, let's just beat the hell out of them psychologically and coerce them into a confession. So that's what the polygraph is. It's a psychological billy club that will coerce a person into a confession. It's not a lie detector, and we're stupid if we use it as such, but there are occasions when it's real good to put pressure to bear on a criminal to get a confession.
这是一种该死的绝佳审讯技巧。既然我们不能在身体上把人往死里打，那我们就从心理上彻底击垮他们，强迫他们招供。这就是测谎仪的本质。它是一根心理警棍，能强迫一个人招供。它不是测谎器，如果我们把它当作测谎器用，那我们就是蠢货，但有些时候，给罪犯施加压力以获取供词是非常有效的。
So I see you have some gear here.
我看到你这里有一些设备。
Yeah. Let me just-- so basically, what we have here is a very antiquated, very crude instrument. It was invented in 1922, and it hasn't changed significantly since it was invented in 1922. The polygraph test itself-- poly meaning many, and graphos meaning tracings, is what the polygraph stands for. So the many tracings that the polygraph records are your blood pressure, your pulse rate, sweat activity on your hand, and your breathing.
是的。让我来——所以基本上，我们这里有一个非常古老、非常粗糙的仪器。它发明于1922年，自发明以来就没有发生过重大变化。测谎测试本身——“poly”意为多，“graphos”意为描绘，这就是测谎仪名称的由来。测谎仪记录的许多描记包括你的血压、脉搏、手部的排汗活动和呼吸。
Next thing we're pulling out here is GSR electrodes. They record what's known as the galvanic skin response, which is basically just increase or decrease in the sweat activity in your hand. This here is just a cardio cuff, similar to what the doctor uses to test your blood pressure in a doctor's office.
接下来我们拿出来的是GSR电极。它们记录的是所谓的“皮肤电流反应”，基本上就是手部排汗活动的增加或减少。这只是一个血压袖带，类似于医生在诊室里测试血压用的那种。
So what we have here is a machine that can watch you breathe, watch two fingers on your right hand sweat, and watch your heartbeat. So the more heinous the crime under investigation, the more likely an innocent person is going to fail.
所以我们这里有一台可以观察你呼吸、观察你右手两根手指排汗、观察你心跳的机器。因此，调查的罪行越恶劣，无辜者通过测试的可能性就越小。
Jake, if you're accused of molesting the 11-year-old neighbor girl, Sally, you're already in a state of shock because just the accusation alone's enough to ruin you. You're sitting there thinking, oh Lord, what will happen to me? I mean, what about my job, my neighbors, my friends, my family? This is just unbelievable. So you're stressed to the max already. You're already starting to sweat just thinking about it.
杰克，如果你被指控猥亵11岁的邻居女孩莎莉，你已经处于休克状态，因为仅仅是指控就足以毁了你。你坐在那儿想：天哪，我会怎么样？我的工作、邻居、朋友、家人该怎么办？这简直不可思议。所以你已经压力巨大了。仅仅想到这件事你就开始出汗了。
I'm already sweating.
我已经开始出汗了。
Exactly. Just thinking about this situation has already got you stressed out, and it's just an imaginary situation. Imagine if it were real.
没错。仅仅想到这种情况就已经让你压力倍增了，而且这还只是一个想象的情况。想象一下如果是真的会怎样。
When did your doubts in the polygraph first begin to manifest?
你对测谎仪的怀疑是什么时候开始显现的？
I'd been at it for a while. And of course, I knew I could control my breathing, but I never could figure out for sure how to control the cardio and blood pressure and the GSR until a friend of mine came in, talking about the pucker factor and tighten up the anal sphincter muscle when he was under stress.
我做了有一段时间了。当然，我知道我可以控制呼吸，但我从来没有完全弄清楚如何控制心脏活动、血压和皮肤电流反应（GSR），直到我的一个朋友过来跟我聊起“收缩因素”，说他在压力下会收紧肛门括约肌。
And so after he left, I just hooked myself up to the polygraph and pumped up the air in the cuff and tightened up my anal sphincter muscle like I was trying to stop a bowel movement, and lo and behold, there was a most gigantic, wonderful, naturally-occurring cardio rise accompanied by a GSR rise. So just by simply tightening up your anal sphincter muscle, you can cause a reaction at will. Then all you had to do was figure out the appropriate time to do it. It takes an a-hole with a little training to beat an a-hole with a little training.
在他离开后，我把自己连上测谎仪，给袖带充气，然后收紧肛门括约肌，就像试图憋住大便一样，结果发现，竟然出现了极其巨大、美妙且自然发生的心脏跳动升高，并伴随着GSR升高。所以，只需简单地收紧肛门括约肌，你就可以随意引发反应。然后你要做的就是找到适当的时机去做。需要一个受过一点点训练的混蛋去打败另一个受过一点点训练的混蛋。
Shortly thereafter, I quit. I wrote a letter of resignation. I was a cryptographer in the military studying cryptography, so I started each sentence with a different letter, just as my own little private joke. If you looked at the first letter of each sentence in my resignation letter, it spells out "bullshit."
此后不久，我就辞职了。我写了一封辞职信。我在军队里做密码破译员，研究密码学，所以我用不同的字母开始每一个句子，这只是我自己的一个小玩笑。如果你看我辞职信中每个句子的第一个字母，拼出来就是“bullshit”（胡扯）。
And I commenced my crusade. I bought a polygraph instrument. I got an old 1967 Chevy Panel Truck. I rigged it up, where I could live in it, and made me a little fold-down bed, porta-potty. Put me in some water supply. Put me in a little Coleman camp stove and a little homemade desk that I could fold my bed out and put my little homemade desk up there and put my typewriter on there. So I would just live in my little '67 Chevy Panel Truck and work construction jobs enough to keep body and soul together.
然后我开始了我的征程。我买了一台测谎仪。我弄了一辆1967年的雪佛兰厢式货车。我把它改装了一下，可以住在里面，做了一个小折叠床、便携式马桶。装上了供水系统。放了一个小科尔曼露营炉和一个我自己做的小桌子，这样我就可以把床折叠起来，把桌子架好，放上我的打字机。我就住在我的这辆67年雪佛兰厢式货车里，靠打零工维持生计。
And I would just moved from city to city. Started down in Houston, and then Dallas, and Fort Worth, and Indianapolis, then Chicago, and various other places. Every city had their own talk show host. And then back then, out in front of every convenience store, there used to be a whole bank of payphones. I conducted hundreds of radio talk shows standing in a phone booth outside 7-Eleven clerks, swatting off mosquitoes and what-have-you.
我只是从一个城市搬到另一个城市。从休斯顿开始，然后是达拉斯、沃思堡、印第安纳波利斯，然后是芝加哥和其他各种地方。每个城市都有自己的脱口秀主持人。在当时，每个便利店前面都有整排的公用电话。我站在7-Eleven便利店外的电话亭里，拍打着蚊子之类的东西，主持了数百场广播脱口秀。
Every time I went on a radio talk show, I was a great success. I'd light up the phones like crazy. Everybody had a horror story about a polygraph test. Then I would put on seminars. The seminars would be very simple. I'd done them in union halls, churches, people's living rooms. I've had as low as five people and as high as close to 5,000.
每次我上广播脱口秀节目，我都很成功。我会让电话线爆满。每个人都有关于测谎测试的恐怖故事。然后我会举办研讨会。研讨会非常简单。我在工会大厅、教堂、人们的客厅里都办过。参与者少至五人，多至近5000人。
I have a polygraph up there. I'd say, OK, here's the deal. I'm going to teach you, in five minutes or less, how to control every tracing on this polygraph chart. Then I'd look around the audience and I'd find the one who had the most skeptical look on their face, and I'd point to them and I'd say, you don't believe a damn word I'm saying, do you? They'd kind of shrug or something. And then I'd say, come up here. Come up here. Then, OK, here how the photograph works.
我那里有一台测谎仪。我会说：好的，交易是这样的。我会在五分钟或更短的时间内教你如何控制这张测谎图表上的每一个描记。然后我会环顾观众，找到那个脸上表情最怀疑的人，指着他说：你不相信我说的一个字，对吧？他们会耸耸肩什么的。然后我会说：上来。上来。好的，这就是测谎仪的工作原理。
OK.
好的。
Come over here and get you hooked up to this machine. Just lean forward and raise both arms. Let me get finished hooking up here and we'll-- so what we're going to do today is, I'm going to set you down here on this little chair and I'm going to hook you up to this so-called lie detector. And in just a matter of a few minutes, I will teach you how to control every tracing on the polygraph chart by simply using what I call mental imagery. So we'll explain more about that here in a minute. Let me get around here and hook up this--
过来，把你连到这台机器上。只要前倾并抬起双臂。让我把连接完成，我们就——所以我们今天要做的就是，我会让你坐在在这个小椅子上，我会把你连到这个所谓的“测谎仪”上。只需几分钟，我就会教你如何通过简单地使用我所说的“心理意象”来控制测谎图表上的每一个描记。所以我们一会儿会对此做更多解释。让我到这边来连接这个——
In order for you to pass this test, you've got to-- telling the truth has nothing to do with it. You've got to produce for the polygraph examiner what he expects to see from a truthful person on this chart. The premise behind the polygraph is that, if you are lying, you will have a reaction on the relevant questions and no reaction on the control questions.
为了通过测试，你必须——说实话与测试毫无关系。你必须在图表上为测谎仪操作员呈现他期望从一个诚实的人身上看到的反应。测谎仪背后的前提是：如果你在撒谎，你在相关问题上会有反应，而在控制问题上没有反应。
Now, what are the relevant questions? Well, the relevant questions are obviously those that pertain to the pointed issue. For instance, if the test is about whether you leaked the information to The Washington Post, then the questions would be pertaining to that leak. Did you tell The Washington Post reporter about the president's speech? Do you know anyone who had access to the president's speech that may have given it to The Washington Post? On and on.
现在，什么是相关问题？显然，相关问题是那些与重点议题有关的问题。例如，如果测试是关于你是否向《华盛顿邮报》泄露了信息，那么问题就会与该泄露事件有关。你告诉《华盛顿邮报》记者关于总统演讲的事了吗？你知道谁有权接触总统的演讲稿并可能把它给了《华盛顿邮报》吗？等等等等。
They will then intersperse questions called control questions. The control questions are innocuous questions that have nothing to do with the pointed issue. They are completely irrelevant. Have you ever lied to anyone in authority to keep from getting in trouble? Have you ever stolen anything? All those types of irrelevant control questions.
然后他们会穿插一些被称为“控制问题”的问题。控制问题是与重点议题毫无关系的无害问题。它们完全无关。你曾经为了不惹麻烦而对权威人士撒谎吗？你曾经偷过东西吗？所有这些类型的无关控制问题。
And then what I want you to do is just basically relax on the relevant questions and then show me a nice little reaction-- think of something frightening-- on the control questions. So here we go. I want you just to close your eyes and relax.
然后我想让你做的就是：在相关问题上保持放松，然后在控制问题上表现出一个不错的反应——想一些令人恐惧的事情。所以，我们要开始了。我要你闭上眼睛，放松。
I want you to picture yourself lying on a beach chair, staring out at the ocean. You're watching the waves gently rolling into the shore. Wave after wave gently rolling into the shore.
我要你想象自己躺在沙滩椅上，凝视着大海。你看着海浪轻轻地涌向岸边。一波又一波海浪轻轻涌向岸边。
Now, I instruct you to do this. When you hear the relevant questions and label the relevant questions and answer the relevant questions, you will only picture yourself lying on this beautiful beach, and you will only see the waves gently rolling into the shore. Relevant questions, wave after wave. Relevant questions, gently rolling into the shore. Relevant questions, totally relaxed, calm, and at peace.
现在，我指示你这样做。当你听到相关问题并标记相关问题并回答相关问题时，你只会想象自己躺在这个美丽的沙滩上，你只会看到海浪轻轻地涌向岸边。相关问题，一波又一波。相关问题，轻轻地涌向岸边。相关问题，完全放松、平静，心境平和。
Open your eyes. You know that relaxed feeling you've got right now?
睁开眼睛。你知道你现在那种放松的感觉吗？
Yes.
是的。
The way to trigger that is to simply label the questions as relevant questions in your mind before you answer them. And then you've got to be able to manipulate a reaction on the control question. So in order to manipulate a reaction on a control question, I want you to live through your most frightening experience or your worst fear on the control questions, OK? What kind of frightening scenario are you going to run through your mind?
触发这种感觉的方法就是：在回答相关问题之前，在脑海中简单地将其标记为相关问题。然后你必须能够在控制问题上操纵出一种反应。所以为了在控制问题上操纵出反应，我希望你在遇到控制问题时，在脑海中重温你最可怕的经历或你最深的恐惧，好吗？你打算在脑海中运行什么样的恐惧场景？
Going spelunking and losing my flashlight.
去探洞，然后弄丢了手电筒。
Oh, that would do it. I would absolutely-- there would be claw marks. My fingernails would be gone, and I'd be stark raving mad in a matter of about five minutes.
哦，那肯定行。我绝对——会有抓痕。我的指甲会没掉，我会在五分钟内完全疯掉。
OK, so that's what you're going to do. Now, what we're going to do instead of asking you actual questions, I'm just going to say, "relevant," and you'll think "relevant" in your mind and answer yes. And then I'm going to say, "control," and you'll think "control" in your mind and answer no on the control questions, OK? OK. Now we're going to put some air in the cuff here. And then we're going to get this show on the road.
好的，这就是你要做的。现在，我们要做的不是问你实际的问题，我只是会说“相关”，你在脑海中想“相关”并回答“是”。然后我会说“控制”，你在脑海中想“控制”并回答“不”，好吗？好的。现在我们要给袖带充点气。然后我们就开始吧。
Relevant.
相关。
Yes.
是。
Relevant.
相关。
Yes.
是。
Control.
控制。
No.
不。
Control.
控制。
No.
不。
Above all else, the devil hates to be mocked, and I'm mocking him. I'm showing them for the frauds and the con men that they are, and they despise me for it. The things that motivated me to stop using this and start fighting it were in part my guilt for having done it and trying to make restitution for all that I'd done, but also the knowledge that people were being absolutely destroyed by this in so many ways.
最重要的是，魔鬼讨厌被嘲弄，而我正在嘲弄他。我向人们揭示了他们是骗子和诈骗犯的本质，他们因此而鄙视我。促使我停止使用这种东西并开始反抗它的原因，一部分是我对自己曾经所作所为的内疚，想为我做过的一切进行补偿，但还有一点是因为我知道人们正以各种方式被它彻底摧毁。
I used to hear them brag in their polygraph meetings that, well, I hit the local drugstore for 50 tests to fail two openings. What that means is they've called 48 other people liars when they may or may not have been lying just so that they can continue to run polygraph tests at $250 a whack. Polygraph operators were just ripping people off and destroying people's lives just so that they could unjustly enrich themselves.
我以前在测谎会议上听他们吹嘘说：嗯，我去了当地药店做了50次测试，搞砸了两个职位空缺。这意味着他们已经把48个人说成是骗子，尽管他们可能根本没有撒谎，只是为了让他们能以每次250美元的价格继续进行测谎测试。测谎操作员只是在坑人，毁掉人们的生活，好让自己非正当地致富。
In 1985, I was finally invited to go testify in Congress.
1985年，我终于被邀请去国会作证。
For the consideration of the bill HR 1212, which the clerk will report by title.
审议众议院第1212号法案，由秘书宣读法案名称。
A bill to prevent the denial of employment opportunities by prohibiting the use of lie detectors by employers--
一项防止雇主通过禁止使用测谎仪来剥夺就业机会的法案——
There was a big gallery. A lot of news people and stuff back there and a lot of spectators and stuff. And during the first two or three testimonies, there was a hubbub in the back, kind of like a murmuring and people talking to one another like they weren't paying attention because they were all spouting the same old company line and everything.
观众席里人很多。后面有很多新闻界人士之类的，还有很多旁观者。在前两三次证词期间，后面有一阵喧哗，有点像低语声，人们互相交谈，好像没在注意听一样，因为他们都在滔滔不绝地讲着同样的老调子。
This is a rights vote, and what separates us from the Soviet Union is a debate that's going on in this House today.
这是一场关于权利的投票，而将我们与苏联区分开来的，正是今天在众议院进行的这场辩论。
And so I start. And I still remember how I started. I said, my name is Douglas Gene Williams, and I plead guilty to crimes against humanity. I was a right-wing terrorist. I tortured thousands of people, documented more confessions than most Gestapo agents, violated countless constitutional rights, and had absolutely no regard for human dignity. I was a well-trained terrorist. And my weapon of choice was the polygraph.
于是我开始作证。我仍然记得我是如何开场的。我说：我的名字是道格拉斯·吉恩·威廉姆斯（Douglas Gene Williams），我承认犯有反人类罪。我曾是一个右翼恐怖分子。我折磨过数千人，记录的供词比大多数盖世太保特工还要多，侵犯了无数宪法权利，且完全不尊重人类尊严。我曾是一名训练有素的恐怖分子。而我选择的武器就是测谎仪。
And I noticed, as I was going through that, the murmuring stopped. It became dead silent. And then I started with the rest of my testimony. And I sat there and waxed eloquent for quite some time.
我注意到，当我讲这些时，私语声停止了。变得死一般寂静。然后我开始了其余的证词。我坐在那儿，滔滔不绝地讲了好一会儿。
Now, I remember when I finished testifying, there was a horrific uproar from the crowd. Flashbulbs going off, people saying, we want to interview you, blah, blah, blah, blah, blah. It was amazing. And then here comes Chairman Martinez, wading through the crowd. Then he said, we've never had a polygraph operator come up and testify to the truth of the problems with the polygraph. And he said, I really think this is the missing element that will enable us to get this bill passed into law.
记得当我作证结束时，人群中爆发出一阵巨大的骚动。闪光灯闪烁，人们说：我们要采访你，等等等等。这太惊人了。然后主席马丁内斯（Martinez）穿过人群走过来。他说：我们从未有过测谎操作员主动站出来作证测谎仪存在的问题。他还说：我真的认为这是让我们这项法案通过成为法律所缺失的一环。
It was just unbelievable. That testimony there led to me going on CBS Night Watch and, just a few months after that, going on CBS 60 Minutes and radio talk shows. It was an unbelievable response.
这简直不可思议。那次作证直接促使我上了哥伦比亚广播公司（CBS）的《夜巡》（Night Watch），仅仅几个月后，又上了《60分钟》节目和各类广播脱口秀。反响惊人。
Just how easy is it to lie and get away with it? And is it possible to beat a lie detector test?
撒谎并侥幸逃脱到底有多容易？有可能打败测谎测试吗？
It's a sad, sick joke, this antiquated last vestige of witchcraft.
这是一个悲哀而病态的笑话，这是巫术的最后残余。
Doug Williams, a former police sergeant and polygrapher, has performed more than 6,000 tests. He knows as much about lie detector tests as anyone. And he says they don't work.
道格·威廉姆斯，一名前警佐和测谎员，已经进行了超过6000次测试。他对测谎测试的了解不亚于任何人。而他说，它们根本没用。
Well, Jack, it would be unethical to tell you exactly how to beat it. But the bottom line is that you can control it with breathing and the tightening of certain muscles.
嗯，杰克，告诉你如何打败它的确切方法是不道德的。但归根结底，你可以通过呼吸和收紧特定肌肉来控制它。
And after that--
在那之后——
[BEEPING]
[哔哔声]
It sounds like we're about to run out, but I felt like there was finally a very real chance of destroying this terribly abusive, evil industry. And I was successful in doing that to a large part in 1988. The Employee Polygraph Protection Act was passed. And it put hundreds and hundreds of polygraph examiners out of business.
听起来我们快没时间了，但我感觉终于有了一个非常真实的机会来摧毁这个极其滥用、邪恶的行业。我在1988年在很大程度上成功做到了这一点。《员工测谎保护法》通过了。它让成百上千的测谎操作员失去了工作。
Where were you when you heard that that was going to become law?
你听说它将要成为法律时你在哪儿？
I was laying on the couch, and I was watching the news.
我正躺在沙发上，看着新闻。
Lie detectors. They've been around for a long time now, 75 years.
测谎仪。它们已经存在很长时间了，75年。
And it said--
上面说——
But a majority of states don't allow--
但大多数州不允许——
--the Senate passed into law in the Employee Polygraph Protection Act, which prohibits the use of the polygraph in the private sector. It is now a federal crime if an employer requires an employee to submit to a polygraph examination.
——参议院通过了《员工测谎保护法》，该法禁止在私营部门使用测谎仪。如果雇主强制员工接受测谎，现在就是联邦犯罪。
It was almost like I was picked up off of that couch and just raised above the heads of these millions of people who no longer had to be subjected to this trauma, and that I was just being held up there, and now I could live. It was a physical sensation as well as an emotional and mental sensation. I could feel myself literally physically being lifted up off of that couch. It was almost as though I could hear the cheers and the laughter and the joy coming from all these people. It was an amazing experience.
我感觉就像被人从沙发上拉了起来，高高托举在数百万不再需要遭受这种折磨的人群头顶，而我就被托在那里，现在我可以活下去了。这既是一种身体上的感觉，也是一种情感和精神上的感觉。我能感觉到自己真真切切地从沙发上被托了起来。我仿佛能听到从这些人心中传出的欢呼、笑声和喜悦。那是一次奇妙的经历。
If you'll look back in history, anybody that's ever done anything-- and I'm not putting myself in their shoes or elevating myself to their status at all-- but like Solzhenitsyn or Mandela or some of the other ones who had spent their life in protesting and dissidence-- and I'm reminded of that picture of the Chinese man in Tiananmen Square a number of years ago. There he stood, hand up, stop, hand up in front of the tank, whole line of tanks.
如果你回顾历史，任何做过大事的人——我并不是要把自己放在他们的位置或将自己提升到他们的地位——但就像索尔仁尼琴或曼德拉，或者其他那些一生都在抗争和持不同政见的人——我想起了多年前那位在天安门广场的中国男子的照片。他就站在那儿，举起手，拦截，举手站在坦克前，整排坦克前面。
Now, he knew that wasn't going to end well for him. He knew that was not a rational act. But something inside of him compelled him to stand up in front of that tank and raise his hand in protest, and I can totally relate to that.
现在，他知道那对他来说不会有好的结局。他知道那不是一个理性的行为。但内心深处有什么东西驱使他站在坦克前，举起手进行抗议，我完全能感同身受。
I was charging windmills. I mean Don Quixote was mentally healthy compared to me. I really did. I looked at myself as a guerrilla soldier, waging a one-man war against what I saw and still see as an oppressive, abusive industry. And I vowed to myself that I would do whatever it took, for as long as it took, to destroy that oppressive industry.
我是在挑战风车。我是说，与我相比，堂吉诃德简直精神正常。我真的这么想过。我把自己看作一名游击战士，对我所看到的并至今认为是一个压迫性的、滥用的行业发动了一场孤胆战争。我对自己发誓，无论花多长时间，付出什么代价，我都要摧毁那个压迫性的行业。
In 1996, the internet was just beginning to get started and I registered the domain name polygraph.com. I am the first one to ever put what they call an ebook on the internet. I charged $47.45 each, and I sold in excess of $200,000 worth of books every year for about--
1996年，互联网才刚刚起步，我注册了域名polygraph.com。我是第一个在互联网上发布所谓“电子书”的人。每本收费47.45美元，我每年卖出的书价值超过20万美元，持续了大约——
This call is from a federal prison.
这通电话来自联邦监狱。
My name is Doug Williams, and I'm the only licensed polygraph examiner to ever tell the truth about the so-called lie detector. Before you take a polygraph test, you must get properly prepared. Remember, failing to prepare is simply preparing to fail. So go to the store page of this website, get my manual and online video or DVD, look them over a few times--
我的名字是道格·威廉姆斯，我是唯一一个站出来揭露所谓“测谎仪”真相的持牌测谎员。在参加测谎之前，你必须做好充分准备。记住，准备不足就是为失败做准备。所以去这个网站的商店页面，获取我的手册和在线视频或DVD，多看几遍——
And then, I guess by popular demand, people kept calling me and writing me and emailing me and saying, man, I understand what you're saying in the manual, but I need to know for sure that I can pass this test. This is the only hurdle I have to pass. I said, well, I've got my own polygraph. I'll just set up my own little deal and bring them in and let them practice on it and make sure they know what they're doing.
然后，我想应广大观众的要求，人们不断给我打电话、写信、发邮件说：伙计，我理解你在手册里说的话，但我需要确定我能通过这次测试。这是我必须跨越的唯一障碍。我说：好吧，我手里有测谎仪。我这就架起我的小玩意儿，把他们叫来，让他们练习一下，确保他们知道自己在做什么。
It worked out real good for everybody. I was making a lot of money and they were getting their jobs that they went for. So yeah, I did that for about 14 years, all the way up to the time I was thrown in prison.
这对大家都很有好处。我赚了不少钱，他们也得到了他们想要的工作。所以是的，我做了大约14年，一直到我被关进监狱。
But by this point, the Employee Polygraph Protection Act was already in place. Why continue with that fight?
但到这个时候，《员工测谎保护法》已经实施了。为什么还要继续那种斗争？
It wasn't a fight. It was a service at that point because people had to take a polygraph test to get every kind of job with the police department, intelligence agencies, the Secret Service, on and on and on, and they knew that it was a joke. So yeah, it was a service. And it was still somewhat of a crusade because I would love to see, and I have advocated that we expand the Employee Polygraph Protection Act to protect all employees, not just private employees.
那不是斗争。那在那时是一项服务，因为人们在获得警察局、情报机构、特勤局等各种职位时都必须接受测谎，而他们知道那是一个笑话。所以是的，这是一种服务。而且这在某种程度上仍然是一场十字军东征，因为我很乐意看到，我也一直在倡导，我们应该扩大《员工测谎保护法》以保护所有员工，而不仅仅是私营企业员工。
Would folks come here to Norman to come to your training or would you go to them?
人们是会来到诺曼参加你的培训，还是你会去他们那里？
Both. Most of them, by far, came here because I hate to fly, so I would charge an exorbitant amount of money if I had to go somewhere else, so most of them came here.
都有。绝大多数人还是来到这里，因为我讨厌坐飞机，所以如果我必须去其他地方，我会收取高额费用，所以大多数人还是来了这儿。
How much would you charge per session?
你每次会话收费多少？
$1,000 if they'd come to me, $5,000 if I have to go to them.
如果他们来找我，1000美元；如果我必须去他们那里，5000美元。
Was there anybody-- did you ever have a client who could never figure it out? Who could never learn the techniques?
有没有人——你有没有遇到过一个永远也学不会的客户？永远无法学会这些技巧？
No. Well, you just saw. What's to learn? What's to learn here? Can you think of losing your flashlight when you're spelunking? Can you think about laying on the beach? Can you do those two things, Jacob? Oh, whoa, I don't know. That's pretty hard there. Let me see. Think I'll be able to do that? Yeah.
没有。嗯，你刚刚也看到了。有什么难学的？有什么可学的？你在探洞时能想到丢失手电筒吗？你能想到躺在沙滩上吗？雅各布，你能做这两件事吗？哦，哇，我不知道。那很难。让我看看。我想我能做到吗？是的。
The United States of America versus Douglas G. Williams, a dramatic reading. "First Undercover Operation." "On or about October 15, 2012, Undercover A placed a telephone call to Williams' telephone number listed on the Williams' website, which connected Williams to his personal cellular telephone."
美利坚合众国诉道格拉斯·G·威廉姆斯（Douglas G. Williams）一案，剧本朗读。“第一次卧底行动”。“在2012年10月15日左右，卧底A拨打了威廉姆斯网站上列出的威廉姆斯的电话号码，该号码连接到了威廉姆斯的个人手机上。”
It was a series of calls, actually, over a period of days.
其实那是一系列的电话，持续了好几天。
"Undercover A told Williams that he was an inspector at an airport and was under investigation for allowing a friend to pass through customs with contraband. Williams promised to assist Undercover A to get ready and told Undercover A, 'There's not going to be one problem at all.' Undercover A informed Williams that he intended to lie to investigators about his involvement in illegal smuggling."
“卧底A告诉威廉姆斯，他是一名机场督查，因为允许朋友带着违禁品通过海关而正接受调查。威廉姆斯承诺协助卧底A做好准备，并告诉卧底A：‘一点问题都不会有。’卧底A告知威廉姆斯，他打算向调查人员撒谎，隐瞒自己参与非法走私的事实。”
And he just kept calling and kept calling. He was the first-- the only-- the first one-- only one that had ever come out and said to me that he intended to lie. Nobody else had ever said anything like that.
他就是一直不停地打、不停地打。他是第一个——唯一一个——第一个——唯一一个站出来对我说他打算撒谎的人。从来没有人对我这样说过。
"Williams chastised Undercover A, saying, 'What the fuck do you think you're doing, dumbass? Do you think you have like a lawyer confidentiality with me?' Williams continued, 'I haven't lived this long and fucked with the government this long and done such controversial shit and got away with it by being a dumbass.' Williams then threatened not to conduct the training for Undercover A, stating, 'I don't know if you've got sense enough to keep your damn mouth shut.'"
“威廉姆斯责骂卧底A说：‘你他妈在干什么，笨蛋？你以为你跟我有什么律师保密特权吗？’威廉姆斯继续说，‘我活了这么久，跟政府斗了这么久，做过这么多有争议的事情，还能侥幸逃脱，靠的绝不是当个笨蛋。’威廉姆斯随后威胁如果不给卧底A进行培训，说道：‘我不知道你有没有脑子把你的臭嘴闭上。’”
He was so pathetic, his pleading voice. And he kept calling me back and kept pleading and kept pleading and kept pleading.
他当时听起来太可怜了，声音带着乞求。他一直给我打回电话，不停地求，不停地求，不停地求。
"After Undercover A asked if there was any way Williams would train him, Williams stated, 'I'm just working on the assumption that you're telling the truth.'"
“在卧底A询问是否有办法让威廉姆斯训练他时，威廉姆斯说道：‘我只是基于你是在讲真话的假设下工作的。’”
See, that protects me. You don't have to turn around and say, yeah, like I told you, I'm a lying son of a bitch. What the fuck was the reason for that, unless you wanted it on the record that I was knowingly teaching someone how to lie and cheat?
你看，那是在保护我。你不需要转过身来说：没错，就像我告诉你的，我是一个骗子。如果不为了让记录显示我是在故意教某人撒谎和作弊，那说这种话有什么意义呢？
About three hours later, I called him back and I said, you are a believer, right? He said, yes. And I said, well, I'll tell you what. I'll help you out here because I just don't want to see you have to suffer for one mistake and be accused of things that you didn't do. And so--
大约三个小时后，我给他回了电话，我说：你是个信徒，对吧？他说：是的。我说：好吧，我跟你说吧。我会帮你的，因为我只是不想看着你因为一个错误而遭受痛苦，并被指控你没有做过的事情。所以——
"On or about October 27, 2012, Williams met Undercover A at a hotel in Arlington, Virginia, for private, in-person training. Williams stated, 'Now that we're alone in private, tell me what this is all about. First thing's first. You got my money?" God, Steven, I hope you make me a good documentary because this is such bullshit and I'm so fucking sick of reading it, I can't even begin to tell you. You can leave that in the tape if you like.
“在2012年10月27日左右，威廉姆斯在弗吉尼亚州阿灵顿的一家酒店见到了卧底A，进行了私人的当面培训。威廉姆斯说：‘既然我们现在私下里了，告诉我这到底是怎么回事。首先是第一件事。你带钱了吗？’”天哪，史蒂文，我希望你能给我拍一部好的纪录片，因为这太荒唐了，我他妈读这些读得恶心死了，都不知道该怎么形容。如果你喜欢，你可以把这段留在磁带里。
You know, at that point in time, there was not any-- he hadn't told me all this other stuff. They got me in there under false pretenses, saying I already knew about this. There wasn't anything else. Then when I get in there, he said, I've been doing this for quite a few times, and I've been making money doing this, blah, blah, blah. And it's just off-the-wall stuff. I was confused, upset, and like I said, I felt obligated to follow through with the training that he had contracted me to do.
你知道，在那一刻，并没有任何——他没告诉我所有这些别的事。他们用虚假借口把我骗进去，说我早就知道这些了。没有别的。然后当我进去后，他说：我已经做过好几次了，而且我靠这个赚了钱，等等等等。这全是胡扯的东西。我很困惑、不安，就像我说的，我觉得有义务完成他与我签约要做的培训。
"During the training, Williams instructed Undercover A, 'Do not change your story. Do not tell on yourself. And do not admit to ever seeing me or talking to me or anything else.'"
“在培训期间，威廉姆斯指示卧底A：‘不要改变你的故事。不要自我揭发。也不要承认见过我或和我聊过天或其他任何事情。’”
And when it was all over, he gave me a big ol' hug and thanked me for helping him. I even put on my Twitter that I helped another person withstand another traumatic polygraph experience. I didn't think there was anything wrong with anything I did.
当一切结束后，他给了我一个大大的拥抱，感谢我的帮助。我甚至在推特上写道，我帮助了另一个人经受住了又一次痛苦的测谎体验。我不认为我所做的任何事情有什么错。
Pause for dramatic effect. "Second Undercover Operation." Man, is this the biggest pile of bullshit I ever saw in my life.
停顿，为了戏剧性效果。“第二次卧底行动”。伙计，这是我这辈子见过最大的一堆狗屎。
"On or about February 5, 2013, Undercover B placed a telephone call to Williams' personal cellular telephone. Undercover B told Williams that he was employed as at county sheriff and he was applying for a job with the border patrol. During a conversation, Undercover B told Williams that he was worried about answering questions the CBP might ask relating to sex and drugs. Williams told Undercover B, 'I will get you ready. Don't tell me anything that will disqualify you, and I can train you how to pass if you're lying your ass off, so don't worry about that fucking bullshit."
“在2013年2月5日左右，卧底B拨打了威廉姆斯的个人手机。卧底B告诉威廉姆斯，他是一名县警官，正在申请边境巡逻队的工作。在谈话中，卧底B告诉威廉姆斯，他担心回答海关及边境保卫局（CBP）可能提出的关于性和毒品的问题。威廉姆斯告诉卧底B：‘我会让你准备好的。别告诉我任何会让你被取消资格的事，我可以训练你通过测试，即使你是在胡扯，所以别担心那些狗屎废话。’”
Yeah. He arrived at the appointed time, knocked on the door, and I told him to come in. And then I go through my little exercise and have him close his eyes and read off the little script. I said, OK, think of something frightening on the controls. And that's when he'd said that he had got sexual favors from a 14-year-old girl when he was driving her home, and that he had smuggled cocaine into the jail.
是的。他准时到达，敲了敲门，我叫他进来。然后我做我的小练习，让他闭上眼睛，读出那个小剧本。我说：好的，在控制问题上想一些令人恐惧的事情。就在那时，他说他在开车送一个14岁女孩回家时从她那里得到了性服务，他还往监狱里偷运过可卡因。
"Undercover B tried to further explain his concerns but was interrupted by Williams, saying, "Oh god, please help me. Shut the fuck up. Quit worrying about all that stuff. Listen, I'm fixing to put it all positive, OK?' Williams added, 'I don't give a damn if you're the biggest heroin dealer in the fucking United States.'"
“卧底B试图进一步解释他的担忧，但被威廉姆斯打断，说：‘天哪，求你帮帮忙。闭上你的臭嘴。别再担心那些事了。听着，我要把这一切都转变成积极的，好吗？’威廉姆斯补充道：‘我才不在乎你是否是他妈的美国最大的海洛因贩子。’”
Why are you saying this? Why are you talking like this? And I just lost it. I went crazy in front of him. If you come in here and make these stupid confessions to me, I'm going to give you absolution, you son of a bitch. I'm going to lick my finger and I'll put the sign of the cross on his forehead and I was like, [BABBLING]. Go in peace, my son. [BABBLING], doing my best imitation of a priest speaking in Latin.
你为什么要说这些？你为什么这么说话？我当时心态崩了。我在他面前发了疯。如果你进到这里来对我做这些愚蠢的供述，我会给你赦免，你这个混蛋。我会舔一下手指，在我的额头上画一个十字架，我就像这样：[嘟囔]。走好，我的孩子。[嘟囔]，尽我所能模仿神父用拉丁语说话。
He was sitting there, wide-eyed, and he was getting more pink by the minute. And then finally, I just got right down in front of his face and put my nose right next to his and I said, you about ready to stop this crap and go catch your airplane? "Yes, sir. Yes, sir, I am." And he grabs his backpack and runs out the door and then here comes five federal agents in bulletproof vests.
他坐在那里，瞪大眼睛，脸色变得越来越红。最后，我直接凑到他脸前，把我的鼻子靠在他的鼻子上说：你准备好停止这些胡扯去赶你的飞机了吗？“是的，长官。是的，长官，我准备好了。”他抓起背包冲出了门，然后五个穿着防弹背心的联邦特工冲了进来。
They had this long, drawn-out search warrant all printed up. And they told me, well, this could all be over today if you just cooperate. And I said, man, I don't know what you mean by cooperating. I don't know what I've done. Well, will you talk to us about this? And I said, no, I don't-- I'm not talking to you at all. You call my attorney.
他们打印了一份很长、很详细的搜查令。他们告诉我：嗯，如果你配合的话，这一切今天就能结束。我说：伙计，我不知道你说的配合是什么意思。我不知道我做了什么。好吧，你愿意跟我们谈谈这个吗？我说：不，我——我根本不会跟你们谈。你们去打电话给我的律师。
Up front at 9:30 tonight, a federal investigation has targeted Doug Williams' work. Williams says the federal government alone spends $150 million on polygraph screenings for people working with classified information, but points to the recent cases of Bradley Manning and Edward Snowden as proof the polygraph is far from a foolproof way to stop intelligence leaks. Williams and another anti-polygraph crusader are under federal investigation for their role in teaching techniques to pass the so-called lie detector.
今晚9点半的前线报道，联邦调查正针对道格·威廉姆斯的工作。威廉姆斯表示，联邦政府单单在针对处理机密信息人员的测谎审查上就花费了1.5亿美元，但他指出，最近布拉德利·曼宁（Bradley Manning）和爱德华·斯诺登（Edward Snowden）的案件证明，测谎仪远非阻止情报泄露的万无一失的方法。威廉姆斯和另一位反测谎斗士正因他们在教授通过所谓“测谎仪”技术方面的作用而受到联邦调查。
I do not and will not knowingly assist anyone to lie or train anyone to lie. But by far, the majority of people who are called liars are innocent, truthful people that are falsely branded as liars simply because they're nervous.
我没有也不会明知故问地协助任何人撒谎或训练任何人撒谎。但绝大多数被叫作骗子的人是无辜的、诚实的人，他们被错误地贴上骗子的标签，仅仅是因为他们紧张。
Williams says he refuses to teach people who tell him they want to lie and won't stop working to end the use of the machine he believes is based on faulty science.
威廉姆斯说，他拒绝教那些告诉他想要撒谎的人，并且不会停止工作以终止这种他认为基于错误科学的机器的使用。
They went ahead and indicted me. And the rest of the story you know. They were threatening all sorts of stuff like, OK, well, this guy-- bear in mind, he really wasn't applying for a job. He was already a customs and border patrol agent, but he was claiming that he was trying for a job. They were saying, OK, well, you're helping this guy get a job that he wasn't qualified for, and this job pays $60,000 a year, and he'll be working there for 30 years, so you're going to have to forfeit to the government 30 times $60,000.
他们继续起诉了我。故事剩下的部分你都知道了。他们威胁要搞各种东西，比如：好吧，这个人——请记住，他其实并没有在申请工作。他已经是海关和边境巡逻特工，但他声称自己正在申请工作。他们说：好的，你是在帮助这个人获得他没资格得到的工作，这份工作一年收入6万美元，他会做30年，所以你必须没收给政府30乘以6万美元的钱。
Boy, that can bring pressure to bear on you. And so it was one of those deals where I said, OK, shoot up here amongst us. One of us has got to have some relief. I had pled guilty trying to save myself from being in debt to the government for like $17 million.
天哪，那能给你带来巨大的压力。所以这是那种 deals（交易）之一，我说：好吧，朝我们开火吧。我们中间总得有一个人能得到解脱。我认罪是为了拯救自己，免于欠政府约1700万美元的债。
You were a trained interrogator for many years in the police department. This was your job. You were a professional. Couldn't you tell if a client was unscrupulous?
你在警察局做了多年的训练有素的审讯员。这是你的工作。你是专业的。你难道看不出一个客户是否不讲道德吗？
Boy, you name me one person on the face of this earth that isn't unscrupulous in one degree or another. So how am I going to determine the degree of unscruples? Give me a dying break. You're a trained interviewer. Can you tell at what point I'm BSing you and what point I'm not? No, you can't, and nobody can, in spite of what they say.
伙计，你给我找出世界上一个在某种程度上讲道德的人。那我该如何确定不道德的程度？饶了我吧。你是个受过训练的采访者。你能判断出我在哪一点上在忽悠你，哪一点不在吗？不，你不能，谁也不能，尽管他们怎么说。
OK. So Doug, I just want to go back and, when you first started out training people, did you have any ground rules you drew from?
好的。道格，我想回到你刚开始训练人们的时候，你有制定过什么指导原则吗？
No, I had no ground rules because I never saw the necessity of having any ground rules because no one ever came in and told me they were going to lie, and I never told anyone I was going to teach them how to lie.
不，我没有任何指导原则，因为我从来没觉得有制定指导原则的必要，因为从来没有人进来告诉我要撒谎，我也从没告诉任何人我要教他们如何撒谎。
And you didn't ask any questions?
那你什么问题都没问吗？
OK. You're going to paint me in whatever corner you want to paint me. You just go ahead and paint me. But I never told anyone to lie, nor did anyone tell me they were going to lie, and the government knows that very well because they've interviewed 5,000 people that I trained. Not one of them ever told me they were going to lie. So--
好的。你想把我描绘成任何你想要的形象，你只管去描绘吧。但我从来没告诉任何人撒谎，也没有任何人告诉我他们打算撒谎，政府非常清楚这一点，因为他们面试过我训练过的5000人。他们中从来没有人告诉过我他们打算撒谎。所以——
Doug--
道格——
OK, god.
好的，天哪。
I'm not mounting a federal investigation against you.
我不是在对你进行联邦调查。
Well, you certainly are. You're sitting there, saying that it was incumbent upon me to inquire as to whether or not a person is guilty of a crime when they come in and learn about how to pass a polygraph test. It is not incumbent upon me to do that. That is not my job, nor is it my responsibility. I'm neither ethically or legally required to do that.
嗯，你当然是在。你坐在那里，说当一个人来学习如何通过测谎时，我有义务去询问他是否犯了罪。我没有义务去那样做。那不是我的工作，也不是我的责任。无论是从道德还是法律上，我都无此要求。
But were there lines to yourself that you were uncomfortable with crossing?
但有没有你自己不舒服跨越的界限？
I never crossed any lines. What lines did I ever cross? None.
我从来没有跨越任何界限。我跨越过什么界限？没有。
Hello.
你好。
Hey, Doug. How you doing?
嘿，道格。你好吗？
Well, I'm 71 years old and I'm in federal prison. How the hell do you think I'm doing? I was sentenced to two years. I got about another four or five months before I finish my sentence. You hear all the racket in here? 250 guys crammed into a 2-story building about the size of a small apartment complex, living in 12 by 9 rooms, two men to a room. So it's always in the background a constant uproar.
嗯，我71岁了，我在联邦监狱里。你认为我他妈能有多好？我被判了两年。我还有大约四五个月就刑满释放了。你听到这里的所有噪音了吗？250个人挤在一栋两层楼的小楼里，大小大约像一个小型公寓大楼，住在12乘9英尺的房间里，两个人一间。所以背景里总是一片混乱。
I'm in here with a bunch of nonviolent drug offenders or crooked bankers, tax cheats. This is a work prison. All I have to do is clean the windows in the visiting room of the administration building. It takes me about 15 minutes, and then I'm done. Then I go out and work out. I work out twice a day. My goal is to leave here in better shape physically, emotionally, spiritually than I was when I came in here, if, for no other reason, than to show them they can't beat me. But I stay pretty busy. I do a lot of reading.
我和一群非暴力毒品罪犯、腐败银行家或逃税者关在一起。这是一所工作监狱。我要做的就是擦行政大楼探视间的窗户。大约需要15分钟，然后我就完成了。然后我出去锻炼。我每天锻炼两次。我的目标是离开这里时，无论是身体上、情感上还是精神上，都要比我刚来时更好，就算没别的理由，也要向他们证明他们无法打败我。但我保持着忙碌。我读很多书。
Just parenthetically, prisoners are probably the best reviewers of literature that there is because that's all they do is read. They spend hours and hours and hours reading.
顺便提一下，囚犯可能是最好的文学评论家，因为他们除了读书什么都不做。他们花费数小时数小时地阅读。
Have you given any trainings?
你进行过什么培训吗？
Oh, yeah. I've trained quite a few people, yeah, including some of the officers here, because it turns out they are subjected to polygraph examinations on occasion themselves.
哦，是的。我训练过很多人，是的，包括这里的一些警官，因为事实证明他们自己有时也会接受测谎测试。
And you just do it without a polygraph machine? You just do the mental imagery stuff?
你是在没有测谎仪的情况下做的吗？你只是做心理意象练习？
I can teach them without a polygraph. I've done it for years, [INAUDIBLE].
我可以在没有测谎仪的情况下教他们。我已经做了很多年了。
You do it in the cafeteria or in your room or?
你是怎么做的？在食堂里还是在你的房间里？
Wherever. I've beat them everywhere.
随处都可以。我在任何地方都打败过他们。
Do you feel that, if you have indirectly helped someone actually deceive a polygraph operator, that that's a small price to pay for undermining this machine?
你觉得，如果你间接地帮助某人欺骗了测谎仪操作员，那为削弱这种机器付出的一点点代价是值得的吗？
Well, let's put it this way. I have proved conclusively that the polygraph is absolutely worthless as a lie detector. So if there's a crime committed here, the crime is the fraud perpetrated by the polygraph operators in convincing our government and our criminal justice system to rely on an instrument that they know, and I have proven, is absolutely worthless.
嗯，让我们换种方式说。我已经确凿地证明了测谎仪作为测谎器是绝对没用的。所以如果这里犯了什么罪，那就是测谎仪操作员犯下的欺诈罪，他们说服了我们的政府和刑事司法系统去依赖一种他们知道——而且我已经证明了——是绝对没用的工具。
So that sounds like a yes.
那听起来是个“是”。
Well, hell yes.
当然是了，见鬼。
Do you have anything you want to add before we call it a day?
在结束之前你还有什么要补充的吗？
No, just to reiterate once again that I am, in fact, a political prisoner. I am in prison because I have protested the loudest and the longest against the polygraph. Now, if they think throwing me in prison for a couple of years is going to stop me from doing that, they are terribly wrong. If you think I've protested the loudest and the longest before, wait till I get out.
没有，只是再次重申，我实际上是一名政治犯。我身陷囹圄是因为我抗议测谎仪的声音最大、时间最长。现在，如果他们认为把我关在监狱里一两年就能阻止我这样做，那他们就错得太离谱了。如果你认为我以前抗议的声音最大、时间最长，那就等着我出来看看。
That story was produced by Love + Radio. Part of their upcoming season. A quick footnote to the story. Doug says in the story that the polygraph was invented in 1922, but he's misremembering. It's actually 1921.
那个故事是由《Love + Radio》制作的。他们即将到来的一季的一部分。故事的一个小注脚。道格在故事中说测谎仪发明于1922年，但他记错了。其实是1921年。
And also, in case this wasn't clear, he was not the only person to testify to Congress in the 1980s about polygraphs. In particular, there was research by a guy named Leonard Saxe that was very important.
还有，万一这还不清楚的话，他并不是20世纪80年代唯一一个就测谎仪向国会作证的人。特别是，一个叫伦纳德·萨克斯（Leonard Saxe）的人的研究非常重要。
It is true that lie detectors are unreliable at their main job, detecting lies. Innocent people can get nervous and fail. Guilty ones can pass. If you aren't already listening to the Love + Radio podcast, they have many, many powerful, morally complicated stories, produced and edited beautifully, a whole archive. You can find them at loveandradio.org or wherever you get your podcasts.
测谎仪在它们的主要工作——检测谎言上是不可靠的，这是事实。无辜者可能会紧张而导致失败。有罪的人却能通过。如果你还没在听《Love + Radio》播客，他们有许多许多强大的、道德上复杂的故事，制作和剪辑都非常精美，是一个完整的档案。你可以在loveandradio.org或任何你获取播客的地方找到他们。
Coming up, Comey? You Hardly Know Me. That's in a minute from Chicago Public Radio when our program continues.
接下来，科米（Comey）？你几乎不认识我。芝加哥公共广播电台的节目稍后继续。
It's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. Today's program, Mr. Lie Detector, about hiding and revealing lies. There was an interesting moment at James Comey's testimony this week before the Senate Intelligence Committee when Senator Mark Warner asked the former FBI director why he felt it was necessary to write up notes immediately after each time he met with Donald Trump. As part of his answer, Comey said--
这里是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯（Ira Glass）。今天的节目叫“测谎先生”，关于隐藏和揭露谎言。本周在参议院情报委员会对詹姆斯·科米（James Comey）的证词听证会上，发生了一个有趣的时刻，当时参议员马克·华纳（Mark Warner）问这位前联邦调查局局长，为什么他觉得有必要在每次与唐纳德·特朗普会面后立即记录笔记。作为答案的一部分，科米说——
I was honestly concerned that he might lie about the nature of our meeting and so I thought it really important to document.
我真的担心他可能会对我们会面的性质撒谎，所以我认为记录下来真的很重要。
In the back and forth that followed, Senator Warner summarized Comey's statement this way.
在随后的往来问答中，参议员华纳这样总结了科米的陈述。
So in all your experience, this was the only president that you felt like, in every meeting, you needed to document because at some point, using your words, he might put out a non-truthful representation of that meeting?
所以在你所有的经历中，这是唯一一位让你觉得在每次会议后都需要记录的总统，因为在某个时候，用你的话来说，他可能会发布对那次会议的“非真实陈述”？
OK, I'm just going to stop this right there because that is not using his words. The word Comey used was lie. The words that Warner used were non-truthful representation. That's just how toxic the word is, the whole idea of lying is. One of the president's spokespeople responded to Comey's testimony by saying, quote, "I can definitively say the president is not a liar."
好吧，我这就打住，因为那根本不是用他的原话。科米用的词是“谎言”（lie）。华纳用的词是“非真实陈述”（non-truthful representation）。这就是“撒谎”这个词，整个撒谎的概念有多么令人避之不及。总统的一位发言人回应科米的证词时说，引述：“我可以明确地说，总统不是个骗子。”
But you know one of them is lying, either the president's team or the former FBI director, under oath. Either the president asked for Comey's loyalty and pressured him to drop an FBI investigation, or he did not.
但你知道他们其中有一个人在撒谎，要么是总统的团队，要么是宣誓下的前联邦调查局局长。要么是总统要求科米的忠诚并施压让他放弃联邦调查局的调查，要么就是没有。
As we've learned in this program today, polygraphs will not help us get to the truth of this matter. At some point, the only hope is that a liar comes forward and admits the truth in a situation like this.
正如我们今天在节目中所了解到的，测谎仪不会帮助我们找到这件事的真相。在某个时候，唯一的希望就是有一个骗子站出来，在这样的情况下承认真相。
Which brings us to Act two of our program. Act Two, Where the Rubber Meets the Road.
这带我们进入节目的第二部分。第二部分，当橡皮碰到路面时（Where the Rubber Meets the Road）。
This next story is about a guy who-- I say this with respect-- probably would not do very well on a lie detector test, Theo Greenly. Nice guy. Lives in LA. Makes a living as a bartender. And he told us about this lie that had been eating at him for a while, involving a cousin of his. Sean Cole explains.
下一个故事讲的是一个——我怀着敬意说——可能无法在测谎测试中表现很好的家伙，西奥·格林利（Theo Greenly）。好人。住在洛杉矶。以调酒为生。他告诉我们关于一个困扰他很久的谎言，涉及他的一个堂兄。肖恩·科尔（Sean Cole）来解释。
Before I get to the lying part, I first have to tell you about Theo's cousin. He's an artist, famous, as artists go, named Kenny Scharf. Kenny came up in the '80s in New York with the likes of Keith Haring and Jean-Michel Basquiat. He's done a lot of street art like Keith Haring. Except Kenny's stuff is a lot more psychedelic-- trippy collages of cartoon monster faces, super colorful. And he's done huge murals all over New York, and some in LA and Brazil. A recent canvas of his sold for $100,000.
在我讲撒谎的部分之前，我得先告诉你关于西奥堂兄的事。他是一位艺术家，在艺术家中很有名，名叫肯尼·沙夫（Kenny Scharf）。肯尼在80年代在纽约崭露头角，与凯斯·哈林（Keith Haring）和让-米歇尔·巴斯奎特（Jean-Michel Basquiat）齐名。他像凯斯·哈林一样做了很多街头艺术。只不过肯尼的东西更迷幻——卡通怪兽脸的迷幻拼贴，色彩超丰富。他在纽约画了巨大的壁画，在洛杉矶和巴西也画了一些。他最近的一幅画以10万美元售出。
I've always admired Kenny.
我一直很钦佩肯尼。
This is Theo. He's in his early 30s, so about 25 years younger than Kenny. And he'd heard about Kenny for years before he met him. They lived in different cities. Theo had grown up seeing his cousin's art. Kenny seemed like a big deal.
这是西奥。他30岁出头，比肯尼小25岁左右。他在见到肯尼之前就听说过他很多年了。他们住在不同的城市。西奥从小就看着堂兄的艺术品长大。肯尼看起来是个大人物。
To be honest, I guess I've always been a little bit intimidated by him because he lives such this really cool, big life, it seems to me. And so any time I'm around him, I'm always a little quiet and tense. I just never really felt fully comfortable around him.
老实说，我想我一直有点被他吓到，因为他过着那种非常酷、盛大的生活，在我看来是这样的。所以每当我在他身边时，我总是有点安静和紧张。我从没在他身边真正感到完全自在。
Which goes along with the kind of person Theo is in general. During our interview, he used the word "neurotic" twice and the word "anxious" five times, especially as regards to this thing that happened with Kenny a couple of years ago.
这与西奥一般那种人的性格相符。在我们采访期间，他用了两次“神经质”，用了五次“焦虑”，特别是在提到几年前发生在肯尼身上的那件事时。
Theo was at Kenny's house in LA with a bunch of other relatives, some birthday party or something, and they were just standing around talking-- Theo, his mom, his aunt, and his famous, exuberant cousin.
西奥当时和一群亲戚在肯尼的洛杉矶家中，可能是某个生日派对之类的，他们只是站在那儿聊天——西奥、他妈妈、他姨妈，还有他那位著名、热情洋溢的堂兄。
And I think it was Kenny's idea, or maybe my mom's idea to be like, hey, how about some karbombz on your cars?
我想这是肯尼的主意，或者可能是我妈妈的主意，说：嘿，在你们的车上画点“Karbombz”（车炸弹）怎么样？
Karbombz!
车炸弹！
Karbombz. That's Kenny in a YouTube video.
车炸弹。那是肯尼在YouTube视频里说的。
K-A-R-B-O-M-B-Z.
K-A-R-B-O-M-B-Z。
It's this project Kenny's been doing for maybe four years now. He paints his loony cartoon faces on the sides of people's cars with spray paint. This is more from YouTube.
这是肯尼做了大概四年的项目。他用喷漆在人们的车身上画他那种疯狂的卡通脸。这更多来自YouTube。
So what number karbomb is this?
这是第几个车炸弹了？
What is this, 85? I've done almost 200 cars already.
这是什么，85？我已经画了近200辆车了。
Sometimes he paints eyelids over the headlights with a nose and mouth underneath.
有时他在大灯上画眼睑，下面画上鼻子和嘴。
So bring me your car. I'll do your car.
所以把你的车带给我。我会画你的车。
He does it for free for really anyone who asks him to. Just makes you sign an agreement saying you won't, like, tear the door off and sell it to an art gallery. He doesn't want money attached to it. All of his volunteers-- or victims, as he calls them-- are super into the idea. Theo's mom and aunt were super into it.
他真的免费为任何要求他这样做的人画。只是让你签一份协议，说你不会像把车门拆下来卖给艺术画廊那样。他不想钱牵扯进来。他所有的志愿者——或者他所说的受害者——都非常喜欢这个想法。西奥的妈妈和姨妈都非常喜欢。
And I was sort of into it. I was into it, but I remember I didn't want a big, giant thing on the side. I was thinking more of maybe a little secret one up on the top. And he goes, well, then nobody's going to see that. And I thought, oh, yeah, OK. What did you have in mind?
我其实也挺喜欢的。我喜欢这个想法，但我记得我不想在侧面弄个巨大的东西。我当时想的是也许在车顶弄个小小的秘密的。他说：嗯，那样没人会看到的。我想：哦，是的，好的。你有什么打算？
They finally decide on two of Kenny's standard characters, one on each side of the car. The first looks like a Nike swoosh with eyes and a mouth that he calls Yike. The other is basically a cartoon comet hurtling through space, known as Speedy. Kenny starts with that one. He picks up a can of spray paint, walks up to Theo's 2008 Toyota hatchback, and sprays a bright green line from the nose of the car all the way to the back. At which point, he looks at Theo and says, no turning back now!
他们最终决定用肯尼的两个标准角色，车身两侧各一个。第一个看起来像是一个带眼睛和嘴巴的耐克钩子，他叫它“Yike”。另一个基本上一颗卡通彗星在太空中疾驰，被称为“Speedy”。肯尼从那个开始。他拿起一罐喷漆，走到西奥的2008年丰田掀背车旁，从车的鼻子一直到车尾喷出一条明亮的绿色线条。此时，他看着西奥说：现在没回头路了！
I really wanted to like it. I wanted to want it, and I wanted to be cool. And I wanted to think, oh, what a cool, fun thing. All right, you know? Karbombz!
我真的想喜欢它。我想想要它，我想变得很酷。我想：哦，多么酷、有趣的事情。好吧，你知道吗？车炸弹！
Karbombz!
车炸弹！
But I didn't feel that way.
但我没那种感觉。
Kenny paints the whole outline of this shooting comet, rounded front, and these lines radiating off of it along the whole length of the driver's side.
肯尼画出了这颗流星的整个轮廓，圆形的头部，还有沿着驾驶员侧整个长度辐射出去的线条。
And he filled it in, and it was pretty phallic was my first thought. Then I was like, you know, just shut up, Theo. Don't be immature. This is cool and fun. But then he put on a nose, and he does this circle at the front. And I remember just thinking that it looked like the reservoir tip of a condom.
然后他填满了颜色，我的第一个想法是这看起来很像男性生殖器。然后我想：你知道吗，闭嘴吧，西奥。别那么幼稚。这又酷又好玩。但接着他画了一个鼻子，他在前端画了一个圆圈。我记得当时只是觉得它看起来像避孕套的储精尖部。
Theo didn't say anything. He kept his game face on because, again, he wanted to be game.
西奥什么也没说。他保持着冷静的表情，因为，再一次，他想加入其中。
I was trying to be that person, but I'm not that person-- a cool, hip, fun, artsy, exciting person.
我当时试图成为那个人，但我不是那种人——一个酷、潮、有趣、有艺术气质、令人兴奋的人。
That lie he told himself isn't the lie the story's about, but it's a pretty big one.
他对自己说的那个谎不是这个故事讲的那个谎，但那是一个相当大的谎言。
Theo posed for pictures in front of the car-- find them on Instagram, #karbombz-- and then said goodbye to Kenny and got on the road to pick up his then-girlfriend, Shelly, for dinner.
西奥在车前摆拍了照片——在Instagram上找标签#karbombz——然后和肯尼道别，开车去接他当时的未婚妻雪莉（Shelly）吃晚饭。
So I was driving over there. I was like, well, do I like this? It kind of looks like a condom to me is one of the thoughts I have, but it's not just this alarm of, oh my god, it's a condom. It's a condom. It's a condom. It's a condom.
所以我当时开车过去。我在想：好吧，我喜欢这个吗？它对我来说有点像避孕套，这是我的想法之一，但这不只是那种“哦天哪，那是避孕套”的警示。它是避孕套。它是避孕套。它是避孕套。
Right.
没错。
So I was leaning towards not really liking it. But I tend to have that reaction to any change at first. I don't think I've ever gotten a haircut and just been like, oh, great.
所以我倾向于并不真的喜欢它。但我对任何改变往往最初都有那种反应。我不认为我曾经剪完头发只是觉得：哦，太棒了。
Theo parks near Shelly's house, goes and meets her at her door. It may be worth noting that they had only been together about a month.
西奥把车停在雪莉家附近，去门口见她。值得一提的是他们才在一起大概一个月。
And then she comes out and she sees-- we're walking towards the car, and then I see her spot the car and just stop dead in her tracks. And she just stares at it, then she stares at me, then she stares back at the car, and she's like, what is that? And I said, that's my car. My cousin painted a racing stripe on it with spray paint. He's a famous artist. And she was like, Theo, your cousin is not a famous artist.
然后她出来了，她看到——我们正朝车走去，然后我看到她发现了那辆车，原地停住了。她只是盯着它，然后盯着我，然后又盯着那辆车，她问：那是什么？我说：那是我的车。我堂兄用喷漆在上面画了一条赛车条纹。他是一位著名的艺术家。她说：西奥，你的堂兄不是什么著名艺术家。
She was not a fan. She was like, no way. We ended up walking to dinner. She didn't even want to go in the car. She didn't want to be seen in it.
她不是粉丝。她说：绝对不行。我们最后走路去吃晚饭了。她甚至不想进那辆车。她不想被别人看到在那辆车里。
Shelly's reaction was a blow. They broke up not long after that-- not because of the car. But Shelly was merely the first in a movie montage of horrified-- or, at least, confused-- friends and strangers, many of them curious as to why he had a condom on his car.
雪莉的反应是一个打击。他们没过多久就分手了——不是因为那辆车。但雪莉仅仅是那场电影蒙太奇式的朋友和陌生人惊恐——或者至少是困惑——反应的第一人，他们中许多人都很好奇为什么他的车上画了一个避孕套。
I could tell when somebody was thinking it. People would look at it and just kind of be like, oh, well, that's-- that's nice. I'd say, thanks. Yeah, my cousin painted it. He's a famous artist. They'd say, oh, yeah. Does he, um-- does he always paint, uh-- it looks like, um-- and I'd say, a condom? And they'd say, yeah, like a condom.
当有人在想它时我能看出来。人们会看着它，然后有点像：哦，嗯，那——那很不错。我会说：谢谢。是的，我堂兄画的。他是一位著名艺术家。他们会说：哦，是吗。他，嗯——他总是画，呃——看起来像，嗯——我说：避孕套？他们会说：是啊，就像避孕套。
Theo's roommate freaked out. People at the restaurant where he worked didn't know what to make of it. And of course, as problems go, this isn't the most urgent one facing the world today. Basically, a relative had given Theo this gift that made him miserable. But just to underline, this is all happening in Los Angeles, where, to paraphrase an old adage, wherever you go, there is your car. There was no escaping scrutiny.
西奥的室友吓坏了。他工作的餐馆里的人不知道该怎么处理它。当然，说到问题，这不是今天世界上最紧迫的问题。基本上，一个亲戚给了西奥这个让他痛苦的礼物。但要强调的是，这一切都发生在洛杉矶，用一句老话说，无论你去哪儿，你的车都在那儿。没法逃避审视。
Theo had to drive to work, to the store, to friends' houses, and probably he would have felt uncomfortable with any bright green graffiti painted on his car, attracting sometimes yelly attention from strangers. But the condomness, the phallicicity of this particular cartoon, it just carried an extra freight with it.
西奥不得不开车去上班、去商店、去朋友家，而且如果他的车上画了任何明亮的绿色涂鸦，吸引陌生人有时会大喊大叫的注意，他可能都会感到不舒服。但那种“避孕套感”，这幅特定卡通画的生殖器意味，它只是带有一种额外的负担。
The thing is, Kenny's art, there's no fear of sex.
问题是，肯尼的艺术，并不害怕性。
Yes.
是的。
But I'm terrified of sex.
但我害怕性。
Of sex? Really?
关于性？真的吗？
I mean, not really, but it's just I'm not as comfortable about just showing my sexuality--
我是说，不完全是，但这只是我对于表现我的性取向没有那么自在——
Got it.
懂了。
--just out. I'm not that kind of person. I'm not outgoing about that.
——只是表现出来。我不是那种人。我在这方面不外向。
Nor outgoing at all. As he was parking once, a couple of methed-out tweaker guys told him how much they liked the car, which felt like its own kind of put-down.
也不外向。有一次他停车时，几个吸毒的瘾君子告诉他他们有多喜欢这辆车，这感觉像是对他的一种贬低。
And then I decided to do something about it.
然后我决定做点什么。
This was about six months after Kenny painted the car. Theo googled how to remove spray paint from a car. And as with so many problems, the answer is nail polish remover. But he didn't buy enough to get the job done and so, after a few hours, he managed to scrub just half the condom off. The back half. He'd have to come back for the rest later. Still, he was relieved, like an enormous, bright green prophylactic was lifted off his shoulders.
那是在肯尼画完车大约六个月后。西奥在谷歌上搜索如何去除车上的喷漆。和许多问题一样，答案是洗甲水。但他买得不够多，做不了这个工作，所以几个小时后，他勉强擦掉了避孕套的一半。后半部分。他以后还得回来擦剩下的部分。尽管如此，他感到如释重负，就像一个巨大的、亮绿色的避孕套从他的肩膀上移开了。
And then I was going to work one day, and I get a call from my aunt. And she's like, hey, Theo, it's Gayla. What happened? Were you in an accident? I was like, no, I wasn't in an accident. She said, oh. Well, I'm with Kenny right now and he says that your car is on the internet and that you had your door replaced. You must have been in an accident.
然后有一天我要去上班，接到了我姨妈的电话。她说：嘿，西奥，我是盖拉（Gayla）。发生了什么？你出车祸了吗？我说：不，我没出车祸。她说：哦。嗯，我现在正和肯尼在一起，他说你的车在网上，而且你把门换了。你肯定出车祸了。
And I'm trying to put this together. I'm like, wait, what? How'd he see my car?
我在拼凑这一切。我在想：等等，什么？他是怎么看到我的车的？
Someone had taken a picture of Theo's car, put it on Instagram-- #karbombz-- and Kenny happened across it and thought, why is half the paint missing? Theo tells his aunt Gayla, I'm fine, and rushes off the phone. But it was only a matter of time before Kenny caught up with him.
有人拍了一张西奥车的照片，放在了Instagram上——#karbombz——肯尼偶然看到了，心想：为什么漆掉了一半？西奥告诉他姨妈盖拉：我没事，然后匆匆挂断了电话。但这只是时间问题，肯尼迟早会追上他。
The next family gathering at Kenny's place, Theo pulls up to the house, and all his relatives' cars are parked out front, about half of them with karbombz on the side, making Theo feel even worse. It was like he had betrayed the tribe. Theo spent the whole party trying to avoid his cousin, but finally Kenny came up to him and said, what happened to your car?
在肯尼家举行的下一次家庭聚会上，西奥开车到家，所有的亲戚车都停在前面，其中大约一半车身都带着车炸弹，让西奥感觉更糟了。就像他背叛了部落。西奥整个派对都在努力避开他的堂兄，但肯尼最终走到他身边说：你的车怎么了？
And so I said, I had to take the paint off because some kids or somebody tagged it with a paint pen.
所以我说：我不得不把漆擦掉，因为有些孩子或什么人涂了涂鸦。
So kids graffitied over his painting is what you told him?
所以你告诉他孩子们在他的画上涂鸦了？
Yeah. And then he says, well, do you want to come over to my studio again and we'll repaint it? And my heart sank.
是的。然后他说：嗯，你想再来我的工作室吗，我们把它重新画一下？我的心沉了下去。
Remarkably, while Theo had come to the party prepared with a lie, he hadn't imagined how Kenny might respond, like a chess player who'd only bothered to think one move into the future.
值得注意的是，当西奥来参加派对时准备了一个谎言，他没预料到肯尼会如何回应，就像一个只费心想了一步未来的国际象棋棋手。
And I feel guilty about the whole thing. I feel bad that I lied to Kenny. I feel bad that I defaced his art.
我对自己撒的整个谎感到内疚。我对自己撒谎感到难过，对自己损毁了他的艺术感到难过。
Do you want to come clean to Kenny?
你想向肯尼坦白吗？
Yeah. I do want to come clean. I'm terrified to do so. But I think it's the right thing to do.
是的。我想坦白。我对此感到非常害怕。但我认为这是正确的做法。
Two days later.
两天后。
Hello.
你好。
How are you, Kenny?
你好吗，肯尼？
Hey, Sean.
嘿，肖恩。
Good. How are you, Sean?
好。你好吗，肖恩？
Theo goes back into the studio in Los Angeles with Kenny this time. So the two of them are now sitting across from each other. And I'm in a studio in New York. I can't see them. But I can tell Theo's nervous. I'm nervous. For one thing, Kenny had left a message for Theo beforehand saying, since we're meeting up anyway, why don't I just repaint your car outside the radio station? Theo did not return that call.
西奥这次和肯尼一起回到了洛杉矶的工作室。所以他们两个现在正相对而坐。我在纽约的一个工作室里。我看不到他们。但我能看出西奥很紧张。我很紧张。首先，肯尼事先给西奥留了言说：既然我们无论如何都要见面，为什么我不直接在广播电台外面重新画你的车呢？西奥没有回那个电话。
How many karbombz are there now?
现在有多少车炸弹了？
We had told Kenny the story is about the karbombz, but it's really more about Theo. And after a while, I tried to ease us into the topic at hand.
我们已经告诉肯尼故事是关于车炸弹的，但它其实更多是关于西奥的。过了一会儿，我试着把我们引导到当前的话题上。
And has anyone ever sort of expressed any sort of buyer's remorse or--
有没有人表达过任何买家的后悔或——
Their spouses.
他们的配偶。
Oh, is that right?
哦，是吗？
They've gone home and they were like, she hates it, and they'd been painted over. But it's only happened a couple times.
他们回家后，她说她讨厌它，然后它们就被涂掉了。但这只发生过几次。
Well, I've got to say, you know, part of this--
嗯，我得说，你知道，这的一部分——
I really didn't expect Theo to cut to the chase this quickly.
我真的没想到西奥会这么快切入正题。
I've got to come clean with you. I've got to level with you, because a big part of this today is, there's something that I've been wrestling with and have felt really guilty about having--
我得向你坦白。我得跟你说实话，因为今天这很大一部分原因是，我一直在纠结某件事，而且对我有过——
It's OK.
没关系。
--known how to tell you.
——知道该怎么告诉你。
Whatever. Tell me.
什么都行。告诉我。
When I took off the paint--
当我把漆擦掉时——
Right.
没错。
--I told you that it was because some kids tagged graffiti on it. And that's not true.
——我告诉你是由于有些孩子在上面乱涂鸦。那不是真的。
OK.
好的。
I lied to you, and I feel really bad about that. I was getting a lot of attention from it. My girlfriend flipped out. People were joking that-- because, you know, it's pretty phallic. That side of it is.
我对你撒了谎，我对此感到非常糟糕。我因此得到了很多关注。我的女朋友气坏了。人们开玩笑说——因为，你知道，它相当生殖器化。那一边确实是。
You know what? People say that. It's not really supposed-- that's not the intention, but I don't mind that people think that.
你知道吗？人们确实那么说。它并不是真的要——那不是意图，但我不介意人们那么想。
Well, I was wondering about that.
嗯，我刚才在想那个。
Yeah. Everyone thinks that Speedy's a condom.
是的。每个人都认为“Speedy”是一个避孕套。
They do?
他们吗？
Not everyone, but I've gotten a few comments.
不是每个人，但我收到过几次评论。
That's what I was getting. And I was like--
那就是我收到的。我当时想——
A condom?
一个避孕套？
Yeah. And I could--
是啊。我能——
Where the nose is the reservoir tube? Is that it?
哪里鼻子是储精尖部？是那样吗？
Exactly! Exactly.
没错！没错。
That's so funny. Just so you know, you could just tell me, hey, I've got to take this off. It's a little too much.
这太有趣了。跟你说，你本可以直接告诉我的：嘿，我得把这个去掉。这有点太过了。
Kenny said this happens all the time. People paint over their karbombz or get in accidents or just get rid of their cars. It's like any graffiti. You can't expect it to be there forever. In fact, listening to Theo wring his hands all over the place, Kenny was surprised he drove around with the Speedy character for as long as he did.
肯尼说这种情况经常发生。人们把他们的车炸弹涂掉，或者出车祸，或者干脆把他们的车处理掉。就像任何涂鸦一样。你不能指望它永远在那里。事实上，听到西奥到处都在绞尽脑汁，肯尼很惊讶他竟然开着带有“Speedy”角色的车开了那么久。
Well, the reason why is because I wanted to be a fun, cool, exuberant person. But I think I kind of realized I'm not. I'm more subdued and--
嗯，原因是因为我想成为一个有趣、酷、热情洋溢的人。但我认为我意识到我不是那种人。我更内敛，而且——
Blend. You want to blend.
融合。你想融合。
I do create-- yeah, well I want my-- I don't want to be-- did you say blend or bland?
我不创建——是的，嗯我想我的——我不想成为——你刚才说融合还是平淡（bland）？
Blend. Well, both.
融合。嗯，两者都是。
Yeah, both. I don't want to be bland.
是的，两者都是。我不想变得平淡。
Well, why not just do another non-"phallic," quote, unquote, image?
那么，为什么不画另一个非“生殖器”的图像呢？
I don't feel like I can handle it.
我觉得我应付不来。
Well, then take it off. It's OK, really.
嗯，那就把它去掉。真的，没关系。
This is really the thing you want most when you lie to someone and then confess-- to be absolved not just of the lie, but of the supposedly terrible thing you were covering up in the first place.
当你对某人撒谎然后坦白时，这真的是你最想要的——不仅仅是获得谎言的赦免，而且是关于你一开始掩盖的那件据说是可怕的事情的赦免。
The day after this conversation, Kenny invited Theo down to see a mural he was painting in Koreatown and he saw Theo's car in the flesh. He asked Theo to remove the rest of the condom-- sorry, the comet-- immediately just because he felt like his work was being misrepresented. Theo understood and complied. And now Theo doesn't feel like he's misrepresenting himself, either.
这次谈话后的第二天，肯尼邀请西奥去看看他在韩国城画的一幅壁画，他亲眼看到了西奥的车。他让西奥立即清除避孕套的其余部分——抱歉，是彗星——只是因为他觉得他的作品被误传了。西奥理解并照做了。现在西奥也不觉得他在误传自己了。
He still has the other cartoon on the passenger side, but if you happen to see him driving around LA and you only catch a glimpse of the driver's side of his car, you'd never know there was anything interesting about him at all.
他的副驾驶侧仍然有另一个卡通，但如果你碰巧看到他在洛杉矶开车，并且你只瞥见了车身的驾驶员侧，你永远不会知道他身上有什么有趣的事情。
Sean Cole is one of the producers of our program.
肖恩·科尔是我们节目的制作人之一。
Our program was produced today by Karen Duffin. Our team includes Elna Baker, Susan Burton, Ben Calhoun, Zoe Chace, Sean Cole, Neil Drumming, Stephanie Foo, Michelle Harris, Seth Lind, Jonathan Menjivar, Robyn Semien, Christopher Swetala, Matt Tierney, and Diane Wu. Senior producer is Brian Reed.
我们节目今天由凯伦·达芬（Karen Duffin）制作。我们的团队包括埃尔娜·贝克（Elna Baker）、苏珊·伯顿（Susan Burton）、本·卡尔洪（Ben Calhoun）、佐伊·蔡斯（Zoe Chace）、肖恩·科尔、尼尔·德鲁明（Neil Drumming）、斯蒂芬妮·福（Stephanie Foo）、米歇尔·哈里斯（Michelle Harris）、塞斯·林德（Seth Lind）、乔纳森·门吉瓦尔（Jonathan Menjivar）、罗宾·塞米恩（Robyn Semien）、克里斯托弗·斯威塔拉（Christopher Swetala）、马特·蒂尔尼（Matt Tierney）和戴安·吴（Diane Wu）。高级制作人是布莱恩·里德（Brian Reed）。
[ACKNOWLEDGEMENTS]
[鸣谢]
Our website, thisamericanlife.org. This American Life is delivered to public radio stations by PRX, the Public Radio Exchange.
我们的网站，thisamericanlife.org。《美国生活》由公共广播交换平台PRX传送至公共广播电台。
Thanks, as always, to our program's co-founder, Mr. Torey Malatia. You know, I was making balloon animals at a party this week that we had here at the office, and every balloon that I started twisting, Torey just kind of freaked out, saying--
像往常一样，感谢我们节目的联合创始人，托里·马拉蒂亚（Torey Malatia）先生。你知道，本周我们在办公室开派对时，我在做气球动物，我开始扭动的每一个气球，托里都吓坏了，说——
It's a condom. It's a condom. It's a condom. It's a condom.
它是避孕套。它是避孕套。它是避孕套。它是避孕套。
I'm Ira Glass. Back next week with more stories of This American Life.
我是艾拉·格拉斯。下周带着更多《美国生活》的故事回来。
[MUSIC - "LIE DETECTOR" BY THE MIGHTY CAESARS]
[音乐 - MIGHTY CAESARS乐队的《测谎仪》]